for two weeks six months
whoa what was it a cup used by barbados
no although if such a thing existed it
would be very valuable
among all the relics they managed to dig
up one particular object was very rare
it was a vial which contained the animal
god's breath
relics come in every shape and farm huh
anyone with an eye for fine art would
like to add this relic to their
collection
once word got out the futures started
trying to seek it out as well
they've made tons of counterfeits that
can be found everywhere
in response i just bought everyone i
could find irrespective of its
authenticity
we're still at it now i've bought more
than 2
000 fakes to date and the fatoui are yet
to find the real one
whoa you guys are insane
so it means the real one must be out
there somewhere on the black market
right
hmm hi mom will give you a discount on
them if she finds any
because pymon's just great like that
sure you can try to find the real one
i'll take what you find even if they're
fake
once you're done find me at the winery
i'll trade you a beer for every 20 you
find
up
[Music]
so
[Music]
no one escapes my sights
huh
[Music]
bunny
hey go go baron bunny
[Music]
[Applause]
try not to enjoy this too much
[Music]
that's cheating bruh
didn't think we'd find the volunteers in
a place like this as knights
we are taught to hone our investigative
skills
wow very impressed